court hearings will resume today in
lawsuits against radio host and
conspiracy theorist Alex Jones several
families from the 2012 Sandy Hook
massacre are suing Jones for defamation
he is claimed the school shooting was a
hoax a separate defamation suit was
filed by a man who Jones's web site
misidentified as the gunman in the
parklands school shooting in February
Toni Tecopa was here with Jones's
response Tony good morning good morning
well Jones is doing the live I was
talking through a lawyer right now and
that lawyer is arguing that his clients
past comments are protected by what else
free speech and the suit should
therefore be dismissed
now although Jones now admits that the
Sandy Hook shooting was real he stands
by his skeptical message the one he's
been spreading to his more than five
million listeners they staged Sandy Hook
the evidence is just overwhelming for
years on his radio show Alex Jones said
the Sandy Hook shooting which claimed
the lives of twenty children and six
adults was fake
Sandy Hook is a synthetic completely
fake with actors in my view manufactured
Jones was not in the Texas courtroom on
Wednesday where his attorneys tried to
dismiss the first of at least three
defamation lawsuits against the radio
host they're alleging these lawsuits a
conspiracy
instead Jones was at his austin-based
Infowars headquarters addressing among
other things his ongoing legal fight the
parents of six year old Noah Pozner
who was killed in the Sandy Hook
massacre say Jones's followers have
tormented them with death threats
forcing them to move seven times they're
seeking more than a million dollars in
damages bill Ogden represents Noah
Posner's parents they've continuously
been harassed by a number of different
people believing that Sandy Hook was all
pre-planned and it was there to kind of
shock the public into supporting
restrictions to the Second Amendment the
court battle coincides with Spotify his
decision to remove several episodes of
Jones's podcast for violating the music
streaming services hate speech policy
last week Facebook and YouTube removed
eight of Jones's videos for violating
similar policies Casey Newton covers
Silicon Valley for The Verge tech
companies now have to make a decision
about whether they're going to
acknowledge the fact that some of these
people spreading mrs.
information are going to do it for as
long as Facebook and Google and Spotify
will let them now in addition to asking
for the cases to be dismissed Jones also
wants Posner's family to pay him more
than $100,000 in court fees a state
district judge has a month to decide
whether to let this lawsuit involving
Jones and Noah Posner's parents continue
Jones's attorney has not responded to
our request for comment but I'm guessing
the tables gonna have some comments I
can't imagine being a Sandy Hook parent
and having to go through this deal with
somebody like this and and potentially
allegedly being harassed yeah they've
been followed they've been videotaped a
man went to prison for threatening the
death of those parents we just heard
from believable so much drama
so much pain Tony to cope well thank you
Tony